les pesticides liés à la maladie de
parkinson deuxième maladie
neurodégénérative en france après
alzheimer une réalité mise en lumière
par des scientifiques dès les années
2000 les pathologies à terme sont les
maladies neurologiques type la maladie
de parkinson dans le pour lesquels il ya
plusieurs études concordantes qui
montrent que les produits
phytosanitaires sont un facteur qui
participent
qui peut participer à la ligue parkinson
plus exposés aux pesticides
les agriculteurs sont l'une des
populations fortement touchée par
parkinson aujourd'hui sur les vingt-cinq
mille nouveaux cas annuels 2500 viennent
du monde agricole selon l' agence
nationale de santé publique en 2006 le
manque d'information sur la dangerosité
des produits phytosanitaires et est déjà
dénoncée par cet agriculteur sur les
produits qu'on d'emploi nous ce qu'on
voudrait c'est qu'on nous dise ces
produits il y ait quelques elle quelle
incidence
ils ont sur la santé on le voit pour le
parquet une zone par exemple la même
année pour la première fois en france la
justice reconnaisse le caractère
professionnel d'un cas de parkinson
contractée par un salarié agricole se
rend du complot l'autre ensemble ayant
chacun les informations qu'on trouvait
dans la presse ou sur internet mais
toujours lié évidemment à des recherches
médicales que c'est qu'il y avait de
nouvelles informations qui arrivait et
notamment un prix qui avait été décerné
un professeur de médecine
une étude de l'inserm qui avait été fait
à la demande du gouvernement si au vu de
tout ça que le tribunal a opté pour un
deuxième une deuxième expertise puis
finalement dans son jugement définitif
pour reconnaître le lien entre les deux
trois ans plus tard cet homme était le
troisième français à faire reconnaître
par la justice la maladie de parkinson
comme une maladie professionnelle liée
aux pesticides
à l'époque la fnath l'association des
accidentés de la vie
ap là aussi les pouvoirs publics à
s'emparer de la question
on a mis près d'un siècle pour
l'interdire d'utilisation de l'amiante
produit que nous connaissons cancéreux
pour l'homme
elle ne faut pas mettre autant de temps
pour se pencher sur une question qui
touche la santé publique mais aussi
l'environnement
il faudra attendre 2012 pour que l'état
français reconnaisse officiellement
parkinson comme maladie professionnelle
pour les agriculteurs dorénavant un
décret établit explicitement le lien de
causalité entre l'usagé des pesticides
et cette maladie c'est un soulagement ça
va permettre à ces malades à ces
familles d'obtenir cette reconnaissance
de manière plus rapide en plus des
agriculteurs une récente étude française
estime que le risque d'avoir la maladie
de parkinson augmente aussi
significativement pour les riverains
proches des zones agricoles
[Musique]